What will you never get a second chance for?
To create the first impression!
We humans are generally too judgmental.
Aren’t we?
Why do we come to a conclusion based on our initial
feeling or impression?
Who or what influences us in our decision making?
Let’s find that out!
There is a psychology behind our initial impression.
It’s called the Halo effect .
It is explained as the behavior where we evaluate
other qualities of a person or a thing
based on their single quality.
How?
Let’s understand this.
Imagine you’re streaming music online
and you loved the voice of a particular singer.
Now mentally, you start creating an image of that person.
She might be beautiful, may be she has
high mental and emotional quotients, and so on.
Here, the Halo effect has come into action unknowingly.
No matter what her other qualities are,
your perception about her is based entirely on her voice.
We judge a movie by its trailer, don’t we?
That’s the Halo effect.
A two minute trailer has the power to influence us
into watching a movie.
We even judge a video by its thumbnail.
Funny, isn’t it?
Famous personalities endorsing products works right?
That's because of the Halo effect.
How?
You admire your role model
and have a positive impression about them.
And this in turn makes us have similar
positive impressions about the endorsed products.
And we end up buying them!
Now the question is, how does the Halo effect occur ?
Well, our brain usually takes shortcuts.
What does this mean?
Analyzing a lot of complex information
is a very difficult task for our brains.
So, instead of looking into every quality of a person or a thing,
our brain picks up only the most prominent quality
and predicts the nature of other qualities based on one single quality.
Does we end up taking biased decisions.
We know that we all have experienced the Halo effect at some point.
We sometimes even know that we are judging a book by its cover.
But we still do it.
Do you think we can overcome the Halo effect?
To be precise, can we control our first impression behaviour?
Is it possible?
If it occurs so quickly and unknowingly,
can we prevent our brains from taking quick judgements?
What do you think?
This is your kyu box to explore.
Let us know your interesting answers in the comments section below.
Do Subscribe to this channel to be a part of our amazing community!
And if you have learned something new today,
do Share this video with your loved ones.